we're going to talk about how we farm
because it has a huge impact on the
environment whether it's soil
degradation from growing crops all the
emissions from flying produce around the
world so the future of farming and the
food we eat is a big issue and days the
government's announced today that
farmers will be paid to look after
england's soil
which is an important carbon store of
course
how
important a moment is that is this a big
step to making farming more
sustainable i think it's a vital step
but i don't think it's big step and i
don't think it's big enough for the same
government that calls themselves climate
leaders every two seconds um i
see that giving and empowering farmers
to be able to farm their own land and to
make sure it's regenerative and purpose
is so important but soil degradation
definitely is important but it's only
one part of the farming system that has
to change we have to start looking away
from monocultural farming that's causing
issues within biodiversity and the soil
in itself you know we have to start
looking at how do we build regeneration
um and into our farming systems and
that's really important not just for the
farmers and our environment but also for
the food we eat for the nourishment we
get these are all things that will be
greatly affected if we don't change the
way that we farm well yes and it's such
a complex issue isn't it david we can
only touch on some of the issues but not
only has farming got a role to play in
helping mitigate against climate change
protecting the soil being example but
farming is also affected hugely by
climate change certainly in in some
parts of the world
yeah i think most scientists believe
that through direct temperature effects
most crops will have we'll see declines
in their yields over the next few
decades um you also have to deal with
the fact that climate change is making
pest
infestation more common it's making
weather patterns more
erratic both in the case of you know
droughts and heat waves but also in the
case of flooding all of which can be
devastating for crops last year in the
u.s american farmers made more money
from insurance payouts than they did
from actually selling their crops to the
market
and when you think globally and how
interconnected we are how globalized our
food system is it's no it's not really
the case that for most parts of the
world you know a crop failure um in one
in one corner of the planet doesn't mean
anything it affects um everything even
if it's not directly affecting the
amount of food that we'll be having in a
place like the us of the uk it will
affect food prices which um are going to
be is a difficult problem for those who
are already living um on the edge of of
um hardship with food or who have a hard
time getting the food they need as we've
seen with so many other um products over
the last few months the global supply
chain is really fragile um the food
supply chain is as fragile okay and
climate change is going to make it much
harder to move that food around the
world sorry to cut in i just want to
give days one more answer on the issue
of imported food 80 percent of food in
the uk is imported i mean that's going
to have an impact in terms of air miles
but also
some farms in other countries might have
lower environmental standards there are
so many issues here days aren't there
exactly and i think we have to remember
like especially as an island we are so
vulnerable to the changes within food
systems and the way uh imports come in
um and i think we notice that with
covert so if we don't have the right
soil if we don't have the right
processes to grow food at home as well
in order to meet the demands what
happens if there is another shortage
what where does that leave us where does
that leave the average person where does
that leave the people who are most
excited okay